>> OFFICIALS SAY THAT MORE THAN
100 AFTERSHOCKS HAVE ROCKED THE
AREA INCLUDING ONE THAT WAS
NEARLY AS STRONG AS THE MASSIVE
--
LOOK AT THE BUILDINGS JUST
COLLAPSING INTO DUST.
CNN INTERNATIONAL BANKING
ANDERSON IS IN GAZIANTEP SIR.
KEEP POKING WITH HER EARLIER
THEY WERE INSIDE OF A BUILDING
--
HOPING TO DESCRIBE WHAT YOU ARE
SEEING THIS MORNING.
>> JIM, IT IS HEARTBREAKING.
IT SOUNDS AND THEY MAY JUST BE
ABOUT TO CALL QUIET ONCE AGAIN.
THIS BUILDING BEHIND ME HAS
COMPLETELY COLLAPSED.
AS THE SEARCH AND RESCUE TEAMS
HERE UNDERSTAND THAT THEY
BELIEVE THERE ARE MORE THAN 15
PEOPLE STILL IN THE RUBBLE
BENEATH THIS BUILDING.
IF YOU LOOK TO THE BUILDING ON
THE LEFT-HAND SIDE YOU CAN SEE
THE EXTENT OF THE BUILDING AS
IT STOOD JUST SOME 40 HOURS
AGO.
4:30 IN THE MORNING ON MONDAY.
WE ARE NOW JUST TURNING THAT
GENERATOR DOWN.
I WANT TO STAND OUT OF THE SHOT
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING TO CALL
FOR QUIET.
IT SOUNDS AS IF THEY MAY NOW BE,
ONCE AGAIN, HOPING FOR AN
EXTRACTION.
[WHISPERING]
>> THEY HAVE KEPT THE GENERATOR
ON, WHICH MEANS THEY HAVE NOT
ASKED FOR SILENCE AS OF YET.
THEY HAVE HEARD THE VOICES, JIM,
OF THREE PEOPLE DURING THE
PERIOD OF TIME THAT WE HAVE
BEEN HERE.
THEY ARE HOPING THAT THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO EXTRACT PEOPLE,
ALIVE, STILL FROM HERE.
THERE IS HOPE.
IT HAS BEEN ABOUT 40 HOURS NOW.
IT IS BITTERLY COLD JUST ABOUT
MINUS ONE HERE AT PRESENT IT
WAS BITTERLY COLD FOR 30 ON
MONDAY WHEN THIS EARTHQUAKE
STRUCK.
THERE ARE, POTENTIALLY, POCKETS
BENEATH THIS BUILDING WHERE
PEOPLE COULD STILL BE ALIVE.
OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE BEEN
REPORTING ON THIS THAT PEOPLE
DO SURVIVE.
IF THEY ARE WARM, AND IF THEY
HAVE GOT WATER THEY COULD
SURVIVE FOR AS MANY AS 13 DAYS.
OBVIOUSLY, SEARCH AND RESCUE
BECOMES A RECOVERY SITUATION
THE LONGER THINGS GO ON.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING TO PEOPLE
WHO HAVE GATHERED HERE, PEOPLE
JUST BEHIND ME WITH THEIR
BLANKETS.
THE GROUP OF PEOPLE OVER HERE
FROM THIS BUILDING.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING TO A
GENTLEMAN WHOSE MOM AND DAD
LIVE IN THIS BUILDING.
HE WAS IN TEARS.
HE IS JUST HOPING THAT HIS MOM
AND DAD MAY SURVIVE THIS.
IT IS A DESPERATE SITUATION
HERE IN GAZIANTEP.
WHICH IS IN THE WEST --
APOLOGIES, JUST WATCHING THE
VAN BEHIND ME AS PEOPLE JUST
HOPE FOR SOME GOOD NEWS AT THIS
POINT, JIM.
>> BECKY, WE ALSO KNOW DOZENS
OF COUNTRIES HAVE COMMITTED TO
SENDING A.
AND SOME OF THOSE TEAMS ARE
ALREADY IN THE REGION.
PART OF THE CHALLENGE IN SOME
AREAS IS NOT JUST HAVING ENOUGH
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND BUT
ACTUALLY GETTING TO SOME OF
THESE AREAS.
RIGHT, BECKY?
>> YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
WE CAME IN WITH THE EMERATI TV.
THE UAE HAVE SENT SEARCH AND
RESCUE TEAM.
THEY SENT EQUIPMENT.
HUGE EQUIPMENT!
AMBULANCES AND SEARCH AND
RESCUE VEHICLES.
WE CAME IN ON THAT AID FLIGHT
OVERNIGHT.
AS I UNDERSTAND AS MANY AS 50
COUNTRIES NOW SENDING IN
EQUIPMENT.
SONAR DEVICES.
DOGS.
ASSETS ON THE GROUND.
EQUIPMENT TO ENSURE THAT AS
MUCH IS DONE AS POSSIBLE IN
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT TO
POINT OUT GAZIANTEP IS A
RELATIVELY NEW TOWN.
IT HAS RELATIVELY GOOD SERVICES
HERE.
THE BUILDINGS ARE RELATIVELY
NEW AND RELATIVELY ROBUST.
I HAVE TO SAY AS WE CAME IN
FROM THE AIRPORT, A LOT OF THE
BUILDINGS RETAIN THEIR
STRUCTURE.
IT IS NOT CLEAR AS WE WERE
COMING FROM THE AIRPORT THAT
ALL BUILDINGS BY ANY STRETCH OF
THE IMAGINATION HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED THERE ARE CERTAIN
AREAS IN TOWN WHERE, CLEARLY,
YOU CAN SEE THE SORT OF
DEVASTATION YOU CAN SEE BEHIND
ME.
THAT IS ALL THE WAY UP AND DOWN
THIS AREA.
THOSE TEAMS COMING IN ARE
ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL.
THE TURKISH AUTHORITIES ARE
ABSOLUTELY STRETCHED IN A
RELATIVELY MODERN, RELATIVELY
ROBUST CITY LIKE GAZIANTEP.
YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN TOWNS AND CITIES
AWAY FROM HERE.
PERHAPS AS CLOSE TO THE
EPICENTER OF THIS EARTHQUAKE
BUT, BY NO MEANS, AS ROBUST AS
SAY OLDER BUILDINGS, BUILDINGS
THAT WERE NOT BUILT TO
WITHSTAND A QUAKE LIKE THIS.
DO NOT FORGET, 7.8, THAT WAS
THE FIRST QUAKE --
AS YOU RIGHTLY POINTED OUT,
THERE HAVE BEEN DOZENS OF
AFTERSHOCKS.
SOME OF WHICH HAVE BEEN ALMOST
AS BIG AS THAT ADDITIONAL
SHOCKED.
IT IS UNCLEAR JUST WHAT LEVEL
OF DEVASTATION EXIST OUT OF
THIS MAIN AREA.
IN WESTERN SYRIA, IN TURKEY --
IN ALEPPO, SOMEONE WHOSE SISTER
WAS THERE THEY HAVE NO WATER,
NO ELECTRICITY, NO GAS OR FUEL.
THEY ARE IN A MOSQUE, THE
FAMILY THAT I'M REFERRING TO,
SHELTERING IN A MOSQUE SHE HAS
REPORTED THAT THE BUILDINGS
AROUND HER ARE ABSOLUTELY
DEVASTATED IN ALEPPO VERY
LITTLE AID, AS WE NOW, ARE
GETTING INTO THAT AREA TO GET
AIR JIM?
>> THAT IMAGE OF THE FATHER
HOLDING HIS DAUGHTERS HAND WILL
BE IMPOSSIBLE TO FORGET PICKING
ANDERSON THANK YOU SO MUCH I
SALMA, TRULY HEARTBREAKING
SCENES WE JUST SAW THERE IN
GAZIANTEP.
PEOPLE BURIED UNDER THE RUBBLE
CALLING OUT SOME PEOPLE EVEN
TEXTING FROM UNDER THE RUBBLE.
WE HEARD EARLIER TODAY THAT
PRESIDENT ERDOGAN HAD DECLARED
A STATE OF EMERGENCY FOR THREE
MONTHS.
WE HAVE BEEN HEARING UP TO 70
NATIONS PLEDGING TO SEND HELP.
IS ANY OF THIS HELP GETTING
THROUGH?
WHAT IS THE LATEST ON THE WIDER
RESCUE EFFORTS HAPPENING ACROSS
THE REGION?
>> EXTRAORDINARY REPORTING
THERE, OF COURSE, WITH THOSE
LIVE IMAGES FROM OUR BECKY
ANDERSON.
THAT IS JUST ONE SCENE THAT IS
PLAYING OUT ALL ACROSS THE
REGION THAT VERY DRAMATIC, VERY
DIFFICULT MOMENTS ARE JUST
REPEATING THEMSELVES, OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
THIS IS A MOMENT WHERE THERE IS
JUST THE TINIEST WHO LIVER OF
HOPE THAT THERE MIGHT STILL BE
SURVIVORS BUT YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT A MASSIVE SCALE WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS CRISIS.
SOMETHING ENTIRELY
UNPRECEDENTED, EVEN FOR A
COUNTRY LIKE TURKEY, THAT HAVE
BEEN PREPARING FOR DECADES FOR
AN EARTHQUAKE.
JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF IT
I WANT TO SHOW UP A MAP OF THE
AFFECTED AREA.
AN AREA SO HUGE STRETCHING DOWN
ACROSS SOUTHERN TURKEY INTO
SYRIA.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
SAYS 23 MILLION PEOPLE
AFFECTED.
JUST TRY TO COMPREHEND THOSE
NUMBERS THAT WE HAVE SO FAR.
MORE THAN 5000 PEOPLE KILLED.
HERE IN TURKEY, ALONE, MORE
THAN 22,000 WOUNDED PEOPLE.
PEOPLE WHO NEED MEDICAL CARE!
CLINICS, HOSPITALS.
THIS IS ONLY TO BEGINNING,
RIGHT?
AID WORKERS ARE WARNING THAT
THERE COULD POTENTIALLY BE
THOUSANDS MORE PEOPLE STILL
TRAPPED UNDER THE RUBBLE.
THERE ARE ENTIRE FAMILIES THAT
COULD BE JUST CRUSHED,
DISAPPEARED OVERNIGHT IN THIS
EARTHQUAKE.
IT DID OCCUR, OF COURSE, IN
FOUR IN THE MORNING.
JUST AFTER FOUR IN THE MORNING.
EVERYONE WOULD'VE BEEN HOME,
EVERYONE WOULD'VE BEEN
SLEEPING.
THAT IS WHY YOU ARE SEEING THIS
VERY MASSIVE DEATH TOLL.
THE RESULT OF THAT IS TURKEY
SIMPLY DID NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO FAN OUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, TO FAN OUT ACROSS THIS
DISASTER ZONE IN THE PAST 36 TO
48 HOURS.
THERE WERE PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
WHERE THERE WAS NO HELP.
PEOPLE SAT ON THE STREETS
FREEZING TEMPERATURES, NO FOOD,
NO WATER, NO ACCESS TO
SANITATION.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, NO
INFORMATION.
HERE IN TURKEY ON EVERY TV
STATION THEY ARE ROLLING LIVE
IMAGES, OF COURSE, OF THESE
RESCUE OPERATIONS HAPPENING IN
MULTIPLE TOWNS.
THE FIRST THING YOU NOTICE IN
THOSE IMAGES IS THE FAMILIES.
THE FAMILIES THAT ARE STANDING
THERE, WATCHING THESE RESCUE
WORKERS.
WISHING, HOPING, WAITING,
PRAYING THAT ONE OF THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS IS FOUND ALIVE.
AND EVERY MOMENT PASSES, THAT
HOPE FADES.
>> AS YOU SPEAK WE SEE ONE OF
THOSE RESCUE OPERATIONS LIVE.
WE HAVE LIVE PICTURES COMING
INTO US HERE SHOWING THEIR
RESCUE TEAM ON TOP OF A PILE OF
RUBBLE.
AND AS WE HAVE SEEN, AS YOU SAY,
IN SO MANY PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
PEOPLE RISKING THEIR LIVES TO
TRY TO PULL PEOPLE OUT FROM
UNDERNEATH THAT RUBBLE.
THE SITUATION, AS WE KNOW SOME
OF COULD BE FAR, FAR, WORSE IN
SYRIA.
WHICH HAS BEEN RAVAGED BY CIVIL
WAR.
WHAT DO WE KNOW OF ANY AID THAT
HAS BEEN ABLE TO GET THROUGH TO
THE NORTHWEST?
PARTICULARLY WHEN THE U.N. HAS
BEEN SAYING TODAY THAT THAT ONE
CRUCIAL CORRIDOR THAT LINKS
TURKEY TO SYRIA HAS BEEN
DAMAGED BY THE EARTHQUAKE?
>> IT SEEMS, FOR NOW, AID
WORKERS --
HUMANITARIAN GROUPS, HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO GET AID INTO CRITICAL
AREAS IN SYRIA.
LET ME START BY EXPLAINING THE
CHALLENGE THAT THEY FACE, RIGHT?
YOU ARE LOOKING AT A COUNTRY
THAT HAS BEEN IN CONFLICT NOW
FOR NEARLY 12 YEARS.
THE NORTHWEST OF SYRIA, WHICH
HAS BEEN STRUCK BY THIS
EARTHQUAKE --
AFFECTED BY THIS EARTHQUAKE.
ONE OF THE HARDEST HIT AREAS
DURING THE CONFLICT.
CONSTANTLY BOMBARDED!
IT WAS SHELLING.
THE CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
THERE IS ESSENTIALLY DAMAGED OR
DESTROYED.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A REGION
WHERE HOSPITALS, SCHOOLS,
CLINICS WERE TARGETED.
MANY PEOPLE ALREADY HAD NO
HUMANITARIAN.
HOW THEY ALREADY HAD VERY
LIMITED HEALTH CARE.
YOU HAD 4 MILLION DISPLACED
PEOPLE WHO RELIED ENTIRELY ON
INTERNATIONAL AID BEFORE THIS
EARTHQUAKE.
THEN YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
AUTHORITIES, RULING GROUPS ON
THE GROUND.
GOVERNMENT CONTROL REGIONS.
THERE WE ARE SEEING PRESIDENT
BUSH BOTTLE, THE GOVERNMENT
TURNING TO IRAN.
SUPPORTERS OF THE CONFLICT.
YOU HAVE THE REBEL HELD AREAS
WHERE THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY
STRETCHED IN ON RESOURCES.
LOOK, FOR A VERY LONG TIME
SYRIANS HAVE FELT THAT THEIR
PLIGHT HAS BEEN FORGOTTEN BY
THE WORLD.
I THINK THAT THIS ONLY
COMPOUNDS THAT FEAR, THAT
ISOLATION.
I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE A MORE
VULNERABLE POPULATION BEING
STRUCK BY YET ANOTHER
CATASTROPHE.
THEY HAVE SO LITTLE LEFT TO